[Music]
all right we have the transcript yet the
Ukraine on whistleblower or
whistleblower here say whistleblower
hoax continues today a White House
official army Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander women testified behind closed
doors about as Ukraine call concerns and
President Trump blasted him as quote
another Trumper witness here now with
reaction Senator Lindsey Graham senator
to be a Democrat today this is the depth
of blind rage psychosis and hypocrisy
this is what you think about this you
have to be okay with Hillary stealing
the primary from Bernie got it except
that she violated the Espionage Act you
have to accept that what she did was
subpoenaed emails and bleach pit and
hammers and deletions is okay you have
to accept it she did have a dirty
Russian dossier she tried to use you
have to accept it was okay to use the
unverified dossier even though you
warned five times to get a warrant when
it's unverifiable lie on FISA
applications you have to accept the
outsourcing of intelligence gathering
you have to accept that Ukraine is
allowed to interfere to help her and
it's not a big deal
that's how insane this now is if you're
a Democrat yeah well it's even deeper
you have to accept the president Trump
is president that's the problem they
don't accept the present Trump won the
election and America hates a sore loser
as much as any country on the planet
this is an unfair process being driven
by sore losers and there's not one vote
in the United States Senate to impeach
President Trump based on this phone call
cuz he did nothing wrong
Adams ship is now among Republicans
among Republicans Adam Schiff is now
compromised he is now a fact witness in
this case because this staff had contact
with the non whistleblower will you call
are you able to call Adam Schiff and I
also would like to be very interested if
you can call Joe Biden and hunter Biden
because I happen to believe in my heart
now maybe it's a wat my wild imagination
but if it was vice president true
that well use taxpayer money had a quid
pro quo fire him you get the money don't
fire him no money and hunter with no
experience gets millions I think if it
was Vice President Trump and Don jr. I
think the Democrats would be acting
differently can you call them before
your committee
well I can't call Adam Schiff I mean
we've got Speech and Debate you know
constitutional separations here but
somebody he's investigating a crime
could call Adam Schiff potentially as a
witness no member of Congress is above
the law but congressmen can't call
senators senators can't call the
president cause of separation power but
in terms of Joe Biden hunter Biden yeah
I think somebody definitely needs to
look into this and it was about four and
eight so the Foreign Relations Committee
would have oversight but let me get back
to what's going on in the house in the
history of the country we've never had
the Intelligence Committee participate
in an impeachment inquiry under the
resolution they're going to pass
tomorrow the President's Council cannot
participate in the Intel committee
inquiry so the president's denied right
to counsel and Republicans can't call
witnesses without Schiff agreeing so
this whole thing is a sham do you think
because I believe what I'm holding in my
hands this is a phony resolution this is
fake news this is faded fairness okay so
there's please about half but I believe
you're responsible for this did you put
out you know your petition you got fifty
signatures fifty is a pretty magic
number now my question is maybe we
should have part two and say unless they
do what Newt Gingrich did we still feel
the same way what do you think well I
think Joe Cunningham from South Carolina
is a Democrat holding the first
congressional district he says he's
going to vote for the inquiry and here's
what I would tell congressman Cunningham
you're voting for an inquiry that allows
the Intelligence Committee to do witness
interviews behind closed doors and the
president's counsel is not allowed to
attend the basic premise of due process
is to confront your witnesses the
accusers against you and call witnesses
on your behalf
neither can be done under the
it's resolution this is a crumb of due
process it's not even half a loaf if we
tried to do this to a Democrat they'd be
eating us alive let me just stress this
the Intel committee the President's
Council cannot participate and
Republicans cannot call witnesses unless
Schiff agrees that is a joke and any
Democrat who votes for this I believe is
voting for an unamerican process senator
you've been at a number of the
president's rallies I know the one in
Dallas had like 30 yeah 35,000 people
outside watching okay greatest show on
earth
man that even gets that kind of crowd
but here's my but but here's my my
question to you because I do have the
the honor of doing three hours of radio
and I see my social media and I can tell
you my belief as evidenced by these
crowds in the intensity I have never in
my life
witnessed such resolution and anger that
if the Democrats do this at impeach him
and they can and he's not going to get
convicted in the Senate I believe that
the people that voted for Trump in 2016
and probably many others are going to be
willing to wait in line a month in the
pouring rain and sleet and snow
to vote for Trump and reelect them in
2016 2020 you agree with that yeah the
backlash is going to be wide deep
because what they're doing in the
present Trump is unfair sore losers
can't accept the consequences of losing
an election and this process in the
house is a joke president Trump is being
treated unfairly and most Americans are
going to say so when they understand
what's happening so they're really gonna
help President Trump get reelected with
this aren't they no we're going to take
the house back keep the Senate and the
president's gonna win because of this BS
I agree with you senator thank you left